if you hate t-shirts just click stop
right now dude we're about to talk about
t-shirts I'll give you a few seconds
okay good they gone
all right so you guys email us a lot
requesting specific sins you thought
were funny and be put on a t-shirt if we
only did one shirt with one sin it'd be
hard to satisfy all the different fans
tastes and it's not very cost-effective
to make a hundred thousand different
shirt styles but we wanted to find a way
to make the shirts more about what you
enjoy from the sins videos so what we're
gonna do is create a series of limited
run shirts every month we'll pick one
sin that seems to be a fan favorite put
it on a shirt and sell it until it's
gone when it's gone it's gone baby why
is the wrong guy the first limited
edition sin shirt will celebrate the
everything wrong with Captain America
the First Avenger video and the sin
we've chosen to commemorate is this one
thing's excitement now we're only
printing 25 of these shirts we have no
idea what we're doing that number could
be too low who knows but 25 of you can
own this limited custom shirt the rest
of you cannot draw yeah it's not
personal it's just logistics I won't
even get one so head over to district
lines comm slash cinemasins
or click the link in the annotation and
you can be one of the lucky few to own
the first limited edition cinemasins
t-shirt or get there and find them all
gone and do a Darth Vader know screen I
honestly have no idea when you're
actually watching this video if you have
a favorite sin from a favorite video
that you'd like to have on a shirt let
us know in the comments below or on
twitter at cinemasins
i will call the cinemasins hotline